hey guys
welcome back to another live session by
simply learn
today's topic of discussion is web
development project ideas for beginners
well you can now practically create
applications for almost
everything and even if you think that
your idea
is generic your implementation plays a
key role
so in this session i present to you some
application ideas
that you could build upon depending on
your imagination
and requirement all right so before we
begin let's wait for a while for more
people to tune in
and meanwhile if you haven't subscribed
to our channel already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
all right i think we're good to begin
so once again for all of those who have
joined us now
today's topic of discussion is web
development project ideas
for beginners also just a disclaimer
i've given a few
fancy names for these apps so uh please
don't be hard and judge me
alright so let's just begin
first up we have partner and hobby
now let's face it we all claim to have
hobbies but eventually get
bored of doing them this application
helps you connect with people
around your vicinity who have similar
interests and hobbies as yours
you can reach out to them get together
and work on your hobbies
the app could also allow users to host
events and share their experiences
now this application definitely has
immense business potential
you could monetize your application by
providing certain advanced features
for premium members however when it
comes to difficulty levels
you might want to make sure that you
have good knowledge on database
management and other backend
technologies as well
next up we have data archiver
now there are times when you want to
save certain information like
memes or chats or links or say an
article
now instead of saving them on your
external storage or
cloud you could store them in this
application
now this will act like a repository and
provide quick storage
and access this is generally created for
a more personal usage
and wouldn't provide much business value
as long as you have strong development
skills
this application is not that difficult
to create
at number 3 we have quick eats app
now i'm sure we have a lot of great
cooks among us
here's an application that allows you to
post your dish whenever you feel like it
now a consumer in your vicinity could
place an order for your dish
the application is flexible to allow the
cooks to serve whenever required
now of course this application has a
higher difficulty level
and a great business potential
at number four we present to you memes
and gifs
in this day and age the primary mode of
information transfer
is through memes from local news to
world issues
everything is made a meme out of so this
application
allows its users to create their memes
and gifs with the help of pre-built
templates now the users can also create
repositories and have copyright
permissions
this is a relatively simple application
to create and has a good business value
next up is booktube
now with a nice user interface and a
better review system
you could potentially have a great
alternative
to goodreads and the book version of
imdb
this app allows you to write book
reviews and also request for reviews
from other users
this is a great project for a book lover
and a great web idea for beginners
building a simple version of this would
be easy
although it doesn't have a great
business potential this could be an
excellent project for a novice to
strengthen their resume
at number six we have the notifications
app
this application comes with a simple
user interface
that consolidates all the information
for the user
for example personalized news highlights
veteran report
important tasks on your to-do list
reminders
etc for the day will be provided the
user can also set a time during the day
to notify the user
perhaps while on the metro or on a
morning run
the best part is that it is easy to
create users will gradually get more
done over time and will feel the benefit
of your web applications
although it doesn't have much business
value it is extremely easy to build
it's a perfect web app for beginners
next up is the family app
there are a lot of activities that a
family does together from
shopping to cooking to household chores
and let's face
it almost every member of the family has
their own phone
a family app will include a family
calendar
a list taking app a photo gallery and a
forum
combined these features will help
organize families
saving time and energy statistics show
that the market for such applications
is huge although there are a few apps
already available for users
there's still room for improved
applications it is also a great web app
for your portfolio
as it will present to users a wide range
of development skills
due to the multiple features involved
and lastly we have the bloggers haven
now one of the best web applications for
beginners especially is a blog
you don't need to have expertise on
anything in particular to start your own
website
this application could include anything
you wish to share with the world
it could have your experiences reviews
and ratings
pictures recipes you name it if the app
is well marketed and has a large number
of viewers
you could create a membership and
monetize it it's pretty simple to create
and again
strengthens your portfolio so with that
we
come to the end of this session i hope
these ideas inspire you to create
something of your own
if you have any idea that you wish to
share with us please leave a comment in
the comment section below
thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
you